also are you proud of the boys usa for
making it to the world cup we made it
yeah we made it what's our group you
have mckeven up nope we got iran wait
wait wait speaking of world cup whose
mom has the fattest taste oh my gosh
that's a great [ __ ] question dude
no that is a great question dude are we
bringing everybody into this miles we
haven't talked about your mom's darkness
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
how do you feel about usa making to the
world did we cut out miles mom's section
i don't know we didn't get anything i
promise cause that was a big issue i'm
that's never been an issue is it true
that you don't have brothers because
you've sucked all the milk out of your
mind
is that true i also did hear that i also
that was a rumor that was going on
reddit
you don't got big tits yeah what have
you heard how hot
it goes iran usa that's that's our group
we got one more england iran usa
yeah and then what's the third what's
the fourth one so we're waiting it's
gonna be like ukraine scotland versus
wales so one of those teams so we
definitely scotland got that probably
not and then ukraine is still competing
yeah they're not really taking this
whole war thing seriously
what stops during war
your soccer doesn't stop that's crazy
yeah that's crazy those are your
athletes
get out there bro defend something right
clinch go out there fighting thank you
you can't fight uh lomachenko's fighting
well machenko fighting yeah they're
retired boxers no lobochenko is the
current uh champion oh that's a good
point yeah
this is [ __ ] dude the president
can't be calling it a genocide and then
you go play in the world cup that's
facts also the president called into the
grammys didn't he
did he yep yeah and he's talking about
the power music as uh being you know
something about peace now talk about the
fact that
music the grammys and not the oscars was
that a little that was a shot
at whom say again at whom hollywood to
say we don't need you
music is actually a little bit more
global yes
music is a language no that's actually
true music does uh
what's the word i'm looking for
transcend transcend thank you god that's
[ __ ] so smart
what you laughing out over there dude
what
what you laughing at over there dude
music is the language of what dove just
nothing we actually need your mom's
double d's on this
let's get dangerous no because we need
the american flag because mark your mom
is canadian right yeah no so we got
we got the flags we need you oh yeah
yeah
mom one tip represents the black
community won the puerto rican community
yeah yeah my mom india threw it through
morocco morocco on my side scotland
scott great britain
what why just stop in mind
vala as well well we can't talk about
vala's mom
no you're not
you are on the path you're sitting right
here right now i don't know if you love
your mom if you don't defend her real
talk if you're in a room your mom's tits
could get talked about that's flavor too
all you all are we'll come together
over here yeah
who got the fattest tits
[Laughter]
you're gonna speak the [ __ ] up on anki's
behalf
who your mom i met your mom bro
it's not like another country
they're firm but they're not huge
i'm just joking i'm joking okay did i
meet her i don't think i met her you
might as you got the wedding oh i didn't
actually meet her we drove to the
[ __ ] uh on friday together oh my god
oh if i look at her tits dude jesus
you're crazy that that might mean
they're not that big
yo i didn't say it
andrew's mom's tits look at me
my mom's tits look at her feet
i saw my mom's tit hit something once
and she just picked it up and moved it
out the way
oh my god
okay so yeah so america we got this what
two two teams leave
yeah the top two teams move on okay iran
we got that that's yeah
so it's basically england and the us go
right yeah or scotland scotland could be
in that's true they'll probably also
lose that's true and then uh we got a
group of death canada made it in that's
what people are stoked about
canada versus morocco yeah yeah dubs
people oh that's gonna be fun who's
stoked about canada bro bro
and all the canadians were with this
weekend yeah yeah dove got mad canadian
family dude no words yes yes great you
want to know the best thing about this
weekend with mark in canada what's that
we go to russ did you tell you could say
this what about your french
oh yeah now all of a sudden mark just
speaks french out of nowhere right but
the best thing is
he would to practice we'd be at a
restaurant he'd order in french and then
they would just repeat back to him like
is that all anything else which was just
like a slap oh garbagio
i'm talking about my best friend trying
my hardest using google translate and
ladies like anything else do you want
yeah our last uh waitress is actually
also a french teacher and she drops off
a card at the end and they're going to
start doing zoom sessions yeah oh really
yeah
french is great i've heard dev dove
speakers everything every language that
there's women does speak the language
yeah that's 100 effect right you speak
italian yeah yeah spanish french i don't
i can understand a lot of spanish or i
can do like flirty spanish but andrew is
a spanish guy
you